welcome back to Jubilee I'm Michael I'm
Evan thank you so much for checking out
this episode of odd man out live with
rappers
yeah special edition but first we want
to say a big big thanks to our sponsor
audible for sponsoring this up is
definitely stick around after the
episode for a special offer from audible
and maybe a special performance from
Michael he might be a rapper or might be
a fake rapper will see me but first
here's the episode my boycott is said to
me like he's bigger a $300 belt is made
out of glitter we brought together seven
rappers I am a rapper I'm a rapper I am
a rapper I am a rapper alright I'm a
rapper I am a rapper I am a rapper one
is a liar if the group discovers who the
liar is they'll split a cash prize if
the liar survives he or she wins the
entire prize for the first time ever
we're actually doing it in front of a
live studio are we all independent here
yeah please don't smoke no I started my
own label Colette I wasn't sure about
but I also figure okay
of course they're gonna put somebody in
here that doesn't look like a rapper
it's a tie to throw you off what's your
best song I don't know that song what's
your fans favorite of your songs flexing
it's called flexing okay how are you
it's hard to say well my fans favorite
song is I know I get a lot of support
for the one that's called when they
shoot me in the street when did that
come up oh three years ago I love the
way you're looking at it right now
how did you distribute it how do i
distribute it yeah how'd you get it out
to see on my youtube channel but is your
music on Spotify off the music anywhere
no I'm still trying to work on that can
you give us the first four bars of when
you shoot me in the street when they
shoot me in the street when they shoot
me industry you will laugh hysterically
use humor as a first oh he couldn't spit
four bars of his
most popular song that's so this is
spacious I want to hear four bars of
flexion though flexing on my ex's active
reckless punted on my left wrist and my
necklace I'm flexing flexing slack first
four bars from your salon T mm the most
sadistic wraps of viola flow ballistic
not so twisted [ __ ] with this kid pissed
me off man you don't wanna risk it yeah
that's cool do we think we know how many
projects uh-huh how many projects uh how
many albums good luck you so take it on
your medicine live it like a resident
should have known the match was over
once I put my pencil in cut me open all
you see is black I'm like a pen to them
had a mind swinging all around just like
a pendulum I'm ending them I'm sending
them back to God I'm blessing them
trying to say what they gonna do but
homie I ain't stressing them pH too
basic and I ain't even tested them and
if the homies want the acid Yuka sent
arrested him for 44 it's the score I'm
gonna go to the store
dr. Martens on my feet watch me creep
through these [ __ ] streets
put your [ __ ] to sleep I get out meet
Lee I've been in this thing I'm doing
president win it capped at 89 plus 11
with it the combo pack the head come
with it not all dogs go to heaven with
it I've been bad there's consequences I
draw the line they cross and fences got
the whole damn package not to mention
this confidences complements of a boss
mentality slaying them like a morality
catching signal like a router be to
sweep out the cannibal out of me since
I've been counting these calories
I'll stop beating these lame [ __ ]
when the first beat came on I was like
oh [ __ ] this is a really slow beat and
that's actually pretty challenging for
freestyling
I'm disputing your credits like an
erroneous charge the generation hybrid I
got melodious boss GM twister with the
Rockets he was phony as laws and my flow
is more addictive than some opiates aw I
must save you put a people man they know
me as bard the fam falling out and cally
like my homies Lavoie its te mm you were
spitting on this music as soon as it was
kind of time for everybody to rap I was
like alright yeah yeah yeah yeah go hard
[Music]
I'll really freestyle I like to write my
[ __ ] but that's nice now
this freestyling freak so when you have
hit you better kill every beat when it
comes down to me I'm gonna chop my voice
had a said to me like he's bigger a $300
belt is made out of glitters a
custom-made bill I love my belt and it
is very glittery I voted for DZ because
he was too Vivaro to me he just seemed
like he was really trying to sell it
like really really really over-the-top
also he was really bad at freestyling
sorry DZ you left me hanging caught a
flight guess you're really in my life
thought you were gonna be my wife but
you st. Joe tight he's a real that's him
yeah cuz it would be super committed if
you were the mole and you like drew a
music now ah yeah now you got me now you
got my mind racing can you go like this
yeah yeah wait okay
how long have you been out here New York
uh five years I came out here mostly for
acting really if there was just music I
probably would stay back home in New
York ten Buick is cool super smooth
dudes super New York I definitely
thought he was the mall because he was
so stereotypical
you are an actor I am you are and so
like you could have researched this role
you could be playing the part very well
it's a very large change what's your
favorite wu-tang song mmm bring the
ruckus okay name the members okay let's
see RZA Ghostface Killah ODB Method Man
Siwon name buzzer Ghostface Killah ODB
method very from New York doesn't have a
mom I give me give me give me a second
give me a second I froze up because of
the pressure like they were all watching
me and audience was all watching me I
really am a huge wu-tang fan so
changhie if you watch this video please
don't think that I am NOT I am okay
let's see I got on this on here we go
odd man out I got voted out because I
can't rap so I would get voted out my
name is Jason the comma J Lee or here
with a company called to believe I don't
know who to choose maybe a maybe C we're
really in my heart I'm thinking maybe B
[Music]
I think the audience voted me out
because they weren't close enough to see
my tattoo is really fake the way you're
spitting I'm pretty confident that you
not you not a mole the way you spit
you're not a mole burrowed up in his
exact I'm a thrown back like with Ella
is that think that petty fight give a
dog a bone back write me I'll piece that
KitKat cone yeah Bertram oh you know
what I mean like it's just I'm not hard
I'm just tired today
are you a singer I'm not sing you are my
sunshine I'm not a [ __ ] singers know
that I'll just embarrass myself I'm
married he's gonna start in like Neos if
I could sing I probably further ahead in
my career
mmm-hmm that's a good thing or a bad
thing my producer Luke ooh
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the event of a tie a rap battle oh
god why did I I already offended you
sorry
Malibu's Most Wanted and all that I
don't even know what just say I'm not
trying to even start a rap battle
you got Tim's he got jeans he got watch
he got chained I'm not sure if it's real
I'm not sure is he saying
I gotta go backwards cap the whole thing
throws me off could be an actor you kind
of see himself she called me a
caricature but it's all good I'm not
offended yo I'm just waiting for
honestly this game to be ended because I
trust everybody in this box and I think
we got it all unlock so I'm not a battle
rapper I ain't trying to hurt feelings
but girl over here she had Interscope
dealings and I trust her too and I trust
them to te mm I'm a rapper thank you
yeah bye
so no cash for me
I was pretty proud at like the
stereotypes just not really existing in
that box when I first started wrapping
it was like a joke now we live in a
society where I'm not the person that
gets voted off immediately so
[Applause]
pinwheel robbers against each other the
whole time it's something characters
questioning people the parts around we
have two men I'm a spoken word poet I
perform kind of all over Los Angeles and
I also teach poetry and hip-hop in
detention centers around La with the
organization called New Earth
I did my homework and it paid off I am a
sweetheart
but when it comes to the money dollar
dollar bills y'all
I don't get funny man get it I was not
shocked I like the fact that we have so
many people that were up here that were
different and then the one guy that you
probably wouldn't even think he was the
mole was the mole I feel like as a
rapper who as a woman who's queer for a
long time I felt like I stuck out and
today helped me feel more confident
about knowing my owning my place in the
music industry so I felt good
I love Jubilee whoa that episode was
wild that was crazy I was in the
audience for it and it was a ton of fun
so great that so many good humans came
out of support really appreciate it did
you know who them all was mmm yeah you
did got a lie go back and do it again
Congrats to the rappers for finding them
all not gonna Bowl oh that was bad okay
get your first audio book for free plus
two audible originals when you sign up
for audible for 30 days yep audible
originals are exclusive titles from
accellerate storytellers from worlds as
diverse as theater journalism literature
and more there are so many amazing
audible originals that you can get by
signing up with the link in the
description and thanks for the great
listen guarantee if you don't like
something you can swap it for something
you do like one of my favorite audible
originals I will tell you is heads will
roll it's by Kate McKinnon who's
actually an SNL whoa and Emily Lynn it's
really funny so amazing Meryl Streep
isn't it freaking love Meryl tree yeah
kind of time with Halloween it's it's
awesome so definitely check that out
in a way that you can check that out is
by going to audible.com/veritasium
potable comm slash jubilee use the link
below to get audiobook for free
[Music]
[Laughter]